[Music]
Valentine's Day is tomorrow and there's
a lot of pressure on men to you know wow
they're lady on Valentine's Day what is
it you find that women complain about
the most you've done Studies on this
real actual studies real actual size I
think the thing that women feel
frustrated about is that you know men
walk in the door they expect us to be
lubed they're locked and loaded and
we're supposed to be okay I'm ready
you know reverse cowgirl let's go that's
one thing the other thing is wait a
minute wait a minute
first of all no it's not anyone's
experienced here on Valentine's Day no
they want the flowers and the chocolates
but I thought but I don't know that I
mean the guy do you think that the
woman's hook could be like hooker you're
gonna be a problem at your wife but
you're gonna be a problem
dog you are you I'm sorry pressure
there's not only pressure in that way
but also men in relationships have the
expectation that sex is happening and
that also is a problem for some women
you know it gets to be obligatory the
obligatory duty and you know when men
get complacent they stop doing their
duty you know men need to go down okay
with enthusiasm without hesitation and
you know that's another complaint
[Applause]
another day from that buddy okay well
you know he's
so you're saying that a man needs to
work harder to please the woman put her
in the right mood as you say and it
needs to be is really important I agree
for a place should be core plays
something I always say but make for
place where a place should be part of
should be core play it shouldn't be
something that you do in order to get to
a result it should be something that
occurs all day long with the sexy text
messages with the nice phone calls
taking out the trash I've heard you talk
about that before doing doing the dishes
assisting at home that's foreplay okay
taking out the trash and helping out in
the kitchen is I will get you a honey
okay another thing that's not true so
far everything you said is wrong in your
book you talk about non-sexual ways to
get your partner ready what are you
talking about I mean you talked about
some of those things right there but use
but some of them specifically refer to
the way you look at something right now
you're Georgia screening is the sexy
librarian that's a lot of guys see the
horny librarian
yeah the sexy librarian or in the voice
you know you have to have a deep raspy
sexy I don't have that I don't have this
is my voice this is the voice I have
it's like baby let's do it you know
let's get down and dirty
[Applause]
so you're saying I should artificially
lower my voice this way
what's the glance what would tell me
with the glances your the glances lets
me know sort of like Pavlov's dog that
your glance lets me know that you're
ready and gets me ready okay what is the
sexy eyes what would you be eyes is a
connection you don't even know what sexy
eyes are your here is the a you don't
either but let me ask you quite what if
you and your wife you had a baby and so
now that you think about it see that
baby goes to sleep about 5:30 or 6:00
and then your wife is so tired and
you're tired and and all sudden you
realize no but guys this is day before
Valentine's and we haven't done it for
quite a while how do i what do we how do
we make that happen
[Applause]
and I add to that another hypothesis
what if you want to be sexy but recently
you had your testicles in dry cleaner
[Applause]
some that he still got sperm in there
and he has a baby yeah that's wonderful
but what you said you know the other
thing that I want to commend you for is
that you're still wanting to have sex
there is a lot of there are a lot of men
that after they view their wife having a
baby don't ever look at the vagina in
the same way so I'm so you so we're
gonna meet packie plan
[Applause]
yeah
so the eyes to see say the voice is deep
and the eyes oh is it is it appear out
of the corner of the eye is that what it
is it has to be individually divided
they are doing that to be nice when I
loved our very own killer yeah